the Reverend Billy Graham the world's
best-known evangelist will be buried
next Friday in North Carolina the public
may pay their respects in Charlotte on
Monday and Tuesday when his body will
lie in repose David beg no is inside the
Billy Graham Library in Charlotte near
the place Graham will be laid to rest
good morning David
good morning John when you come to the
library you have to go through the cross
that's exactly how Billy Graham wanted
it you know he hated the idea of a
museum or a memorial that would honor
him but when his family pitched him on
the concept of a library that would be
an ongoing ministry he warmed up to the
idea his funeral will happen here and
we're told the Reverend approved every
aspect of the plan Reverend Billy
Graham's funeral service will be held
under a tent it's a fitting venue for
someone who rose to prominence preaching
under the canvas Cathedral in Los
Angeles invitations to next Friday's
private funeral service have been
extended to President Donald Trump and
all former presidents who were still
alive Barack Obama called Billy Graham a
humble servant who gave hope and
guidance to generations of Americans
I'll touch that podium I can feel a new
strength and a new power come known as
America's pastor he will be buried in a
casket made by prisoners it's a pine
plywood box lined with a mattress pad
spokesman mark DeMoss
said billy graham died at home no one
else was with him except for a nurse his
doctor said Graham just wore out I think
we can say he passed in his sleep it was
described by the nurse and his doctor as
a very peaceful passing he was not in
any pain his life was not without
controversy a taped phone call between
him and President Nixon drew criticism
from the Jewish community his ministry
also supported a ballot measure banning
gay marriage in 2012 while his views
were controversial televangelist joel
osteen
calls him a hero growing up as a little
boy coming from a preacher's kid you
know we watched him on television and so
he was somebody that we always looked up
to and admired Billy Graham will also be
buried here on the library property
right alongside his wife Ruth she's
buried here the grave is very simple but
this is where the Reverend will go Norah
Franklin Graham says he asked his father
daddy what do you want on your tombstone
Billy Graham had a one-word answer
preacher no I love hearing about all
those details David thank you so much